auch keine nudeln mehr bekommen und
jetzt wissen sie nicht wohin mit ihrem
geld kleiner tipp aktien sind jetzt ganz
günstig ist kommen sie grüße sie so soll
bei der börse oder nehme er nicht gerade
ich habe mich wie ist die lage an der
börse zurzeit oder beschissen die
fachleute sagen kapitulation blutbad
jetzt hätten sie noch nicht erleben
keiner weiß geht es noch weiter nach
unten keiner weiß wie das ausgeht das
rennen ich bin optimist dazu sieht ich
schon so lange dabei wenn da drin 20
jahre sitzt der hat schon so manch eine
kleine krise mitgemacht 221 die
dot-com-blase zur atli moerser pleite
jetzt corona virus also da sind die
männer da drinnen schon relativ gut
gefallen sind das sind das stahl harte
kerle die börsianer war sind schon ab
dabei die nerven und auch den rest des
körpers ordentlich straffer wovon sollte
man in diesen tagen die finger lassen
von türklinken klar aber von welchen
aktien
man sollte generell die finger und
seinen knochen aus dem depot lassen
während panikverkäufe panikverkäufe
jetzt alles zu verkaufen
das wäre das dümmste was man machen kann
jetzt kommen die kleinen die sagen ihre
großen stärken auch das muss auch was
machen mutter
steigen sie alle gehen sache raus wir
haben einen herdentrieb der ist immerhin
der börse gewesen und erst besonders
ausgeprägt jetzt scheiße aber was willst
du machen
damit lässt sich richtig geld verdienen
sie haben jetzt echt eine elektro papier
hier zum drehen natürlich man weiß ja
nicht ob das geschäft lauert naja sich
jetzt während dem interview
zusammenreißen ich kaufe eine palette
wodka beim aldi die ist allein und
verderblicher 2 wenn ich wirklich nichts
mehr zu essen kriege dann kriege ich mit
einer flasche wodka auf jeden fall nahm
ein kopfsalat der der mit seinem gold
barren kommt und dann ab raspel muss
darüber gucken wer zuerst klickt ich
oder der andere und zum dritten wenn die
welt wirklich untergeht
sie haben aber auch schon eingebettet
oder ja heute noch nicht gibt es sonst
noch sonst etwas gutes was der virus so
hat also
irgendwelche positiven nebeneffekte ja
wir besinnen uns auf uns selbst wir
kümmern uns um den die italiener stellen
suchen balkon und machen musik das
wünsche ich mich auch in frankfurt aber
wir können ja alle nix von denen hört
man ja gar nichts die bulgaren haben die
auch zugemacht
alles fällt was tue ich wie kann ich die
krise für mich nutzen
konkret sie kennen doch die alten
börsenweisheiten ja wenn das blut durch
die straßen fließt wenn die kanonen am
lautesten donnern wenn die menschen
ängstlich sind dann werden sie ein
bisschen gierig wenn panik am kreis dann
musst du kaufen oder wenn kanone und
dünneren musst du kaufen
jetzt kommen die andere seite die sagt
greife nie in ein fallendes messer an
der börse verdient man schmerzensgeld
zuerst kommen die schmerzen dann kommt
das geld welche aktien haben sie auf
vorrat gekauft auf vorrat habe ich keine
gekauft ich bin an langfristanleger und
das ist der unterschied zu dem die jetzt
raus klappen wenn du langfristanleger
bist und in zeiträumen von 10 20 jahren
denkst und auch so handels hast du immer
gewonnen in 23 jahre sieht die welt
wieder ganz anders aus da werden wir
auch sicherlich wieder die alten
höchstkurse wenn wir in zwei bis drei
jahren überhaupt noch leben und damit
gebe ich soll zum sex die ja it-service
bruns weise sprechen mit jürgen wie kann
ich ihnen weiterhelfen
haben sie mal versucht das gerät aus und
wieder einzuschalten hat nichts gebracht
verstehe
probieren sie doch mal den kanal der
heute show auf youtube zu abonnieren
genau und im zweifel wo ich auch mal den
gefällt mir -button klicken
genau ja ich bleibe in der leitung